Sathya Narayanan: Thank you.
Jeff D'Andria: Can I just do a quick 15-second on.
Sathya Narayanan: Yeah.
Jeff D'Andria: Sure. Something that happened in my session. A student that was in mine, this is a good trick of the trade for your… as we're building resumes and stuff, from my recruiting perspective. So this student said.
Jeff D'Andria: They graduated recently, they were in a 3-year track program.
Jeff D'Andria: And I, rather than, I guess, the 4 or whatever.
Jeff D'Andria: And I mentioned to him, so that's… that's a context unique to you, right? That…
Jeff D'Andria: is very good to call out. Whenever you've kind of gone above and beyond in some context, because I'm going to guess it's more rare, say, to be in that… finishing in 3, so you're going kind of above and beyond, feel free… really important to, like, call things like that out.
Jeff D'Andria: like, on a resume. For a recruiter and a hiring manager, it's good for them to know, oh, this person, like, pushed themselves. And that could be…
Jeff D'Andria: hey, I took all the AP computer science classes or something, like, at my school, I exhausted them, so I actually had to go to community colleges. Like, that's your context, you know?
Jeff D'Andria: So, little things like that are really important to be explicit with the context, they don't know it. Especially… think of it like the Olympic podium, like, third, second, first. We're trying to give them little…
Jeff D'Andria: ways for them to know that out of the 100 applicants, just so you know, this is about me, so that works me up the podium, right?
Jeff D'Andria: Cop.
Sathya Narayanan: The idea of, like, that's what we are hoping, like, kind of the know your niche is going to… that's an example of, like, kind of knowing your unique niche, right, Jeff? Like, that's what you're saying, yeah, yeah.
Jeff D'Andria: You gotta give these recruiters, you gotta… you gotta give them things like that, that they thrive on it, okay?